[Music]
one of the promises that I made when I
started this show is that I would
personally acknowledge legitimate
criticism when it's thrown my way this
acknowledgement is one of the reasons
that I do live Q&A is right here on
YouTube as well as on Twitter and
Facebook and even sometimes when people
come up to me on the street not only do
I genuinely like hearing from you
directly but I think it's important to
hear the bad feedback right along with
the good note I said legitimate
criticism there and not hysterical troll
criticism for example I'm happy to hear
for people who want me to ask questions
differently or have more aggressive
follow-ups or to find alternative guests
or anything along those lines those
qualify as legitimate criticism whether
or not I agree with them the people who
just tell me that I'm a straight white
supremacist neo-nazi all right racist
well let's just say that I'm a little
less likely to engage with you the
Battle of ideas is far more interesting
to me than the battle to be first to
sarcastically respond to a tweet one
criticism that I hear occasionally is
that I'm actually not a real liberal and
I'm secretly a conservative or sometimes
they'll say I'm the only thing worse
than a conservative a dreaded right
winger that is true that I've been
saying for months that defending my
liberal principles is now a conservative
position but am I still a liberal do I
still believe any of the things that
people on the Left believe well since we
have so many new subscribers around here
I thought I'd lay out some of my liberal
cred for you in case you missed it I'm
so for gay marriage but I even married a
guy I'm pro-choice I'm against the death
penalty I'm for social safety net I'm
for a strong public education system I'm
for legalizing marijuana I'm for
reforming our prison system and I'm
against unnecessary Wars and
nation-building there's other stuff too
but I'm pretty sure I just made my point
right there beyond any of those specific
issues though I'm for true tolerance of
opinion and thought my liberalism is one
of a live-and-let-live attitude this of
course is where I diverge from the
modern left I see virtually no diversity
of thought or tolerance of other
opinions on the left today just constant
smearing and slandering of all
intellectual opponent
take a step back for a moment and think
about your friends on the left are they
tolerant of people who aren't for gay
marriage or people who are pro-life
these used to be just political
differences and now they are somehow a
referendum on what type of person you
are and whether you can be in someone's
life at all I wish this intolerance was
an isolated case but not only have I
seen this type of intolerance first and
in my life but I hear it from you guys
every single day I get emails about
marriages breaking up lifelong friends
no longer talking to each other and
people afraid to say what they think
politically because of repercussions
it'll have at work and by the way now
let me reverse that do you know people
on the right who are tolerant of people
who are for gay marriage and who are
pro-choice I actually do plenty of them
including several people who have had on
this show when there's a disagreement I
see way more people on the right
conservatives or libertarian more often
willing to agree to disagree rather than
to defriend or to smear could the right
be better are there real bigots on the
right absolutely and are there real
racists on the right yes of course
without question but by and large these
are the voices from the mainstream right
anymore
let's not forget even Donald Trump got a
standing ovation at the Republican
National Convention when he talked about
protecting LGBTQ rights of course all
this said it doesn't mean that things
are all right with the right right now
just in the last few weeks
Tommy Lehren was let go by the blaze
after she came out as being pro-choice
or at the very least giving a
conservative explanation for abortion by
saying that the government should stay
out of a woman's private life I actually
agree with her rationalization here and
know that that position upsets a lot of
conservatives the immediate reaction to
her comments and her subsequent firing
strike me as the same intolerance we're
used to seeing from the left these days
not from the right and for the record
I've invited Tommy on the show and I've
invited Glenn back back on the show to
discuss what went down between them I
hope that will happen I happen to like
both of them and we all all of us have
views that are inconsistent with our
broader idea
oh geez we're not robots just yet we're
still human oh and yes by the way it is
glands right as a private businessman to
hire and fire people as he sees fit even
if I don't agree with the reason why he
did it
you know another area which I don't fit
into the traditional political box is
gun control I absolutely believe in the
Second Amendment and obviously also
believe that a healthy distrust of
government is an important and key part
of being an American
Democrats often make it sound like
Republicans want every American
wandering the streets with a weapon like
we're in the old Wild West and
Republicans often make it sound like
every Democrat wants to take away their
right to self-defense as for me I
believe that we have the right to bear
arms but also we have to keep these
weapons out of the hands of the wrong
people and perhaps even more importantly
have a real discussion about mental
health which usually has more to do with
these shootings than the weapon itself
as always I'll keep talking about free
speech free expression and the right to
the individual which I believe to be the
most important facets of a truly free
society whether that makes me a limb
tart or a cook serve ative or a
right-wing maniac is for the commenter
is to decide
[Music]
you